what up space fam goes in here from
anime out bro back at it again to
discuss the latest developments in the
one piece story we got a surprise
appearance that might just change
everything in wano so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy one piece
and want to keep the reviews coming
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button with no mercy
if you haven't joined the nakama right
now by hitting that subscribe button and
most importantly hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you wait for the next
intense chapter to drop feel free to
check out our growing one piece playlist
where we got videos about
yonko warlord supernova and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
this chapter is called kibidongo and
it's the realization of what we've been
expecting to happen for a while now tama
uses her dongle powers to turn many
smile users on her side
just like she did with speed since it
worked on speed we could only assume
that it was a matter of time before she
used it on the others
and she does everyone even
eight-year-old tama is playing a part in
this battle i enjoy seeing speed trick
the others
telling them that the special dongle was
given to her by queen
and that they should help them heal
faster you combine speeds attractiveness
level with the placebo effects of the
dongle and you get men straight up
saying they feel better
after taking it at least they think they
do she even tells gifters that it'll
boost their physical strength and so
she gets what she wants while making the
victims extremely excited
and grateful about it speed is doing a
great job here
speed also recalls how tama bravely
wanted to go tonightshima while no one
would let her go
and speed decided to help her we see how
tama has been working tirelessly to
create dango after dongo
she creates so much it looks like she's
fallen into one of mcdonald's ball pits
it goes without saying that this
must be a huge strain on her body
especially for someone who's been
underfed so much but she keeps going
because she dreams of awana without
orochi or kaido
she's sick of always being hungry and
wants to be allowed to have rice too
moments like this not only make you care
about tama they also put into
perspective that there are people out
there who are
always hungry and have to struggle hard
just to have rice
this battle isn't just about luffy
beating a yonko and getting closer to
being a pirate king
it's also about changing people's daily
lives for the better saving them from
the ever present threat and pain of
starvation
this is what i like about luffy's
journey it's not just about becoming a
pirate king for your own sake
it also includes improving the world and
people's day-to-day lives in the process
we see smile user after smile user get
dongles shoved into their mouths
the tama army is growing and you gotta
love to see it we take a break from tama
to join frankie and sasuke who are
engaged in an intense battle
susaki seemed like one of the stronger
flying six members so it's great to see
frankie doing so well i love
to see him lift the dinosaur by his horn
and send him flying frankie's been
pretty great in mono but i don't know if
he'll be able to match the epicness of
riding a motorcycle on big mom's face
this fight is not a fair one though and
you can't necessarily expect a fair
fight when dealing with pirates that's
kind of the point here susaki's gifter
men
grab hold of frankie and he actually
can't move the men are too strong when
working together
sasuke is going to charge into him with
his horn
and there's nothing frankie can do
however tama usop and nami appear
in another classic moment of oda humor
frank is about to ask for help when he's
interrupted by nami and usa bawling
their eyes out and screaming for his
help
it looks like they're being chased by an
army of countless enemy smile users
susaki gets smug saying this is what
happens when you are overwhelmed by
superior numbers
but tama shines and says that's why
she's here
this girl has made a huge difference
she's like an
animal army's kryptonite sasuke then
sees that usop and nami
were of course faking it and the army of
smile users
attacked sasuke in order to help frankie
as tama commanded frankie manages to get
out of the way in time
and as susaki tries to figure out what
is going on ulti and page 1 appear to
tell him that the others are traitors
they don't know exactly why
and how their men turned but hopefully
they don't figure out that tama is
behind it and target her specifically as
ulti is about to cave in nami's head
again nami gets her chance to shine
hitting ulti a flying six-member with
lightning pikachu would be proud sure
it's not a ko and nami knows that ulti
won't be down for long but it's so epic
to see nami hold her own against such a
strong opponent she's really developed
as a fighter more than i ever thought
she would and as a side note i love how
creative oda
is being with these weather based
attacks there's so much potential and
versatility for nami here and then we
see our boy usopp using his
lethal dongle star move which as you may
have imagined
includes him launching tama's mind
control dongles into the mouths of his
enemies
i love how they're not only overcoming
the sheer number advantage of the enemy
they're actually using it to their
advantage by making them switch sides
teamwork is the key here and everyone is
playing a really important role
imagine how much worse the situation
would be if tama didn't make it here
as sasuke is trying to wrap his head
around everything he gets a frankie
sword to the chin
and then frankie gets him good with a
victory v flash
things have taken a complete 180 since
we joined the outnumbered frankie a few
pages ago
we finally returned to sanji who is not
in good shape we're told that sanji
could crush the males but he couldn't
lay a finger on the females so he never
set a chance
and although everything will probably
work out well you can't help but wonder
about sanji's unwillingness to take on
female enemies being a liability for the
crew
they want him to call nico robin and in
exchange they'll free him
black maria reveals herself to be a
complete savage when she says
that she'll break all of robin's limbs
so she won't be able to run away
robin is obviously very useful for them
and they can use her to find the one
piece and when you think about it it's
really cool that luffy already has such
a desired figure on his crew
sanji tells them not to underestimate
robin before we
jump to bao huang the walking and
talking surveillance system but before
that let me know your thoughts here on
sanji
how will he get out of this and do you
think he's still just messing around
until he gets all the information he can
from them i look forward to seeing him
shine more in this arc before it's
through
especially when you got zorro cutting
the strongest creature in the world
nearby
but anyways bao huang spots the red
scabbards in a dark room
they're breathing which is a good sign
but definitely not in good shape
king says he's got his hands full at the
moment another cool update as he was
fighting marco
he does have time though to give orders
for someone else to go and black maria
takes the role on
sanji tells her not to dare go near them
but looks powerless to help
i hate to see sanji so seemingly
powerless at the moment but then we get
the most significant twist in this whole
chapter there are 10 people
in the room it's dark so she doesn't
know who the 10th
is but there's definitely someone there
helping the samurai we're asked who it
could be as we're shown the figure in
shadow who could be just about anyone
and it also seems like there will be a
break next week so we'll have to wait
longer to find out let me know who you
think it is and why
in the comments i can't wait to read all
of your theories honestly i don't know
who it is but with the way things have
been developing with cp 0 being present
i'd like to think it's shanks i saw this
fan made art of the manga volume in wano
where it shows luffy and all four other
yonko
including shanks and blackbeard i've
discussed many reasons why i feel
blackbeard will show up including the
fact that he's an opportunist he is with
moria who has wanted revenge against
kaido forever
and he might want to grab kaido's devil
fruit and complete the op
trilogy if blackbeard does show up as i
expect him to
would it make sense for shanks not to
show up it seems like the perfect
opportunity to get all yonko
including luffy the so-called fifth
emperor to be at the same place at the
same time in mono imagine how huge it
would be for the newspapers the
hype and for everything else if luffy
and his team beat kaido and big mom
then we may never have such a good
opportunity again for all the yonko to
meet the yonko title might even cease to
exist or stop being significant if
two are taken down at the same time for
these reasons along with the fact that
shanks was on roger's crew and knew owed
it and wanted to help him before
it seems to me that he's going to make
an appearance even if
this specific silhouette doesn't turn
out to be him i don't think he'd steal
luffy's thunder or interfere with his
yonko battle
but him being present in case cp 0 or
someone else wants to finish luffy and
his crew after an exhausting battle
makes sense
i could see shanks helping that kind of
way where he's not directly going to
beat another yonko but he's going to
minimize the chances for foul play
like someone swooping in to finish off
the winning side and in the meantime
why not protect the red scabbards again
there are more likely scenarios but it
would be a very cool possibility and the
one i was most excited about considering
since shanks and blackbeard both have
history with odin and possible
motivations for coming to wano it seems
like a missed opportunity if they don't
join the other yonko in wano
even if shanks doesn't play a definitive
role in ending the conflict but as
always let me know your thoughts this is
just me thinking out loud
and that is it for this video if you do
enjoy seeing these one piece chat
reviews and want to keep them coming
channel your inner pirate king and smash
that like button
if you haven't joined the nakama right
now by hitting that subscribe button and
most importantly hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
and while you wait for the next intense
chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i have videos about
the yonko
warlords supernova and much more link to
that
is in the description and i especially
want to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand up all clans in grata the
world acquire respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal dr kortman johnny
boyd draws emperor otaku spidey life
tinel baked buddhist and tungsten tarkis
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky joe stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond rathu and aura
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support morkon that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you